ja lieber liebe freunde verehrte damen
und herren und auch alle angehörigen
aller anderen 67 geschlechter
selbstverständlich das lernt man im
europäischen parlament
zunächst freut mich sehr dass ich auch
in diesem jahr wieder zu ihnen sprechen
darf noch wurde ich also nicht wegen
vermeintlicher hate speech eingebuchtet
auch wenn das männchen unser
außenminister darsteller inzwischen
vermutlich unter anderem auch das mit
seinem zensurgesetz vorgehabt haben mag
aber was nicht ist kann ja noch kommen
und deshalb sollte man gelegenheiten wie
diese hier heute beim gillamoos wo es
bekanntlich ein bisschen robuster zu
geht darum habe ich so viel denken mit
der sachlichkeit für einen politischen
rundumschlag nutzen so lange das noch
geht
nun bin ich zwar heute hier in bayern
aber auch ich möchte zunächst gerne weil
es das ist was die republik im moment
bewegt gerne ein paar worte zu sachsen
verlieren sachsen das ist wenn man der
linken meinungsführerschaft dieses
landes so glauben darf der dunkelste
teil von dunkel deutschland der üble
salon ball schiff ist ja kob augstein
twitterte diese woche das hat martin
sicherheit schon gesagt ich will es noch
mal hier betonen weil das wirklich ist
so enorm ist
vielleicht sollte man eine autobahn
schilder aufstellen willkommen in
sachsen unterschrieb sachsen mit großem
es und großem a um eine geistige nähe
und das muss man sich wirklich vor augen
führen aller sachsen zur as a zu
insinuieren frei nach dem motto sachsen
sei eine nazif erzeugte verseuchte zone
dieses volk kann ich nur unterstreichen
meine damen und herren das ist schlicht
widerlegt werden die menschen eines
ganzen bundeslandes verunglimpft und er
ist damit leider alles andere als allein
sachsen bashing hat grad absolute
hochkonjunktur martin sichert hat er den
spieler titel schon hingehalten das
findet in unserem land statt
und wenn dann übrigens das blieb ist
jetzt unerwähnt kiosk-besitzer in
sachsen etwas sehr kluges machen nämlich
den spiegel in sachsen schlicht nicht
mehr verkaufen was eine gute idee
dann kommt dann kommt unsere große
claudia roth daher unter zensur das
liebe claudia roth ist freiheitliche
marktwirtschaft an jeder anbieter kann
sich selber entscheiden in diesem land
was er verkaufen will und was nicht das
schafft auch ihr grünen nicht weg merkt
euch das ein ein ganzes bundesland seine
menschen werden hier pauschal und auf
heftigste weise verunglimpft weil sich
dort einvernehmlicher und nur zu
nachvollziehbare unmut über die
hereinbrechenden zustände regt eine
regung die ich bin da ganz offen ich
will auch in manchem anderen bundesland
so stark wie in sachsen wünschen würde
ich sage diesen ganzen notorischen
sachsen hassan klipp und klar das
bundesland in dem jüdische eltern ihre
kinder von der schule nehmen müssen weil
sie von ihren mitschülern gemobbt werden
indem davidsterne öffentlich verbrannt
in dem juden auf offener straße mit
göttern traktiert werden und ein
aufgebrachter mob öffentlich brüllt
hamas hamas juden ins gas in deutschland
meine damen und herren dieses bundesland
heißt nicht sachsen sondern berlin da
ist sowas inzwischen möglich und die
sachsen wollen verhindern dass das bei
denen auch möglich ist und da haben sie
verdammt nochmal recht das bundesland
nehmen links krimineller mob über tage
ganze stadtteile in angst und schrecken
versetzt hunderte von polizisten
verletzt und hunderttausende von euro
schaden anrichtet heißt auch nicht
sachsen sondern hamburg und das
bundesland in dem ganze stadtteile
dermaßen außer kontrolle geraten sind
dass sich die staatsgewalt schafft die
staatsgewalt nur noch in
mannschaftsstärke hinein traut heißt
ebenfalls nicht sachsen sondern
nordrhein-westfalen das bundesland
hingegen dass im bildungsmonitor platz
eins einnimmt ist nicht bayern haben wir
sind dicht dran oder hessen sondern das
heißt sachsen
da muss ich nur sagen die sind ganz
schön helle in dunkel deutschland liebe
freunde
[Applaus]
wir sollen also endlich mal vor der
eigenen tür kehren ehe sie
oberlehrerhaft über die menschen dieses
bundeslandes herfallen
meine damen und herren das liegen
wahrhaft ereignisreiche tage wieder
einmal hinter uns in chemnitz wurde
bereits mehrfach angesprochen von meinen
vorrednern wurde der 35-jährige
familienvater daniel hack auf grausame
art und weise umgebracht
die mutmaßlichen täter ein syrer und ein
iraker womöglich hatte ja spd-frau usus
genau solche szenen im sinn hat wie
davon sprach dass das zusammenleben in
deutschland täglich neu ausgehandelt
werden muss die herkunft der täter lässt
darauf schließen dass sie im zuge der
politik der offenen grenze in unserem
land hinein gemerkt sind hier gewerteten
sie sich als abscheuliche lumpen josef
war mehrfach vorbestraft sollte schon
2016 abgeschoben werden
doch wieder einmal hat der merkelsche
chaos start total versagt und die
abschiede frist schlicht verpennt mit
tödlichen folgen und einzelfälle sind
solche taten und täter eben gerade nicht
tötungsdelikten ist die beteiligung von
asylbewerbern relativ gesehen um ein
vielfaches höher als bei der
einheimischen bevölkerung auch wenn das
zum beispiel die tagesschau nicht zur
kenntnis nehmen möchte
und dass menschen deshalb auf die straße
gehen und dort laut vornehmlich aber
strikt friedlich ihren unmut äußern weil
sie davon schlicht ich sag es mal salopp
die schnauze voll haben und angst vor
der zukunft haben das kann ich bestens
nachvollziehen und an die vertreter der
medien die heute sehr zahlreich da sind
ich gucken viele kameras nein diese
ängste schüren wir nicht wir uns
allenthalben unterstellt wird weil
seitens der alternative für deutschland
sondern diese ängste haben die menschen
und sie haben sie bei dieser
regierungspolitik auch völlig zurecht
und wir sind die die das aufgreifen das
ist aufgabe von politik und er scheint
die einzige zu sein die das tun in
diesem land ja ich bin ich bin sogar
stolz auf viele dieser menschen in
sachsen weil sie der lebende beweis
dafür sind dass es doch noch bürger in
diesem land gibt die so etwas sie mut
stolz und den antrieb haben sich und das
eigene zu verteidigen und es dabei
durchaus in kauf zu nehmen von
abgehobenen scheinbar in einem
paralleluniversum lebenden politiker
darstellern von gefälligkeits
intellektuellen von sohn aktivisten wie
aus stein und einige andere von
antifaschistischen hühnerbrust hooligans
und dem rest der gratis mutig mainstream
linken entourage als nazis diffamiert zu
werden
dieses ständige schwingen der nazikeule
ist fast schon so etwas wie ein
einstudierter reflex von linken die
diesen patrioten ihren mut und ihren
stolz meiden weil sie nämlich selbst
nicht davon besitzen
sie können nur mit selbst hasst
pathologischem altruismus und feiger
aggression aus der anonymen masse heraus
aufwarten was für arme würstchen sind
das um auch daran um auch daran keinen
zweifel zu lassen und das ist mir
wichtig dass auch zusagen komplett
abzulehnen ist die von einigen
tatsächlich sehr wenigen demonstranten
ausgehende gewalt gegen unschuldige
menschen mit migrationshintergrund
ebenso widerlich sind rassistische
beschimpfungen und hitler größe
die gibt es es gibt sie sehr vor
ein zelt und ich wüsste ganz gern mal
das kann ich freilich nicht belegen wie
viele von denen die das tun
eingeschleuste provokateure sind da bin
ich mir nämlich keineswegs sicher wie
auch immer wohl immer das herkommt
derlei dinge sind uneingeschränkt zu
verurteilen und es ist traurig denn es
wertet zudem den völlig berechtigten
protest aufrichtiger menschen ab und ist
für die medien das gefundene fressen auf
das viele von denen nur warten aber wie
marginal war der anteil dieser idioten
verglichen mit der überwältigenden
anzahl aufrechter patrioten und was
haben die medien daraus gemacht 7000
8000 rechte insinuieren rechtsextreme
gehen auf die straße so viele gibt es in
ganz sachsen überhaupt nicht das sind
vernünftige bürger die auf die straße
gehen weit weit mehrheitlich das im
übrigen auch auf der gegendemonstration
linke gewalt von der sogenannten anti
vorausging jetzt müßig zu erwähnen dass
typische antifaschistische repertoire
eben stein und flaschenwürfe das
übrigens und das beschämt während der
dem niedergestochenen opfer gewidmeten
schweigeminute und trotzdem
schlussfolgert die ob ihres wirklich
sehr übersichtlichen intellekt zu mit
leidende safwan chemie von der spd
ich zitiere wir sind zu wenig radikal zu
wenig radikal also ton der
bevollmächtigte des landes berlin beim
bund staatssekretärin für
bürgerschaftliches engagement und
internationales da lässt doch ralf
stegner grüßen
man fragt sich wer hat hier eigentlich
ein ungeklärtes verhältnis zur nicht vom
staat ausgehenden gewalt wir sind das
ganz gewiss nicht liebe freunde denn wir
halten am gewaltmonopol des staates fest
wir fordern es ein wir bitten darum dass
der staat sein gewaltmonopol endlich
wieder vernünftig wahrnimmt dann hätten
wir nämlich viele probleme nicht
nun kommt nun kommt diese gemengelage
nicht von ungefähr wenn justiz und staat
versagen dann gewinnt der mob an allen
fronten die oberhand
das ist eine geschichtlich immer
wiederkehrender gesetzmäßigkeit unserem
land droht wenn das hier so weitergeht
großes chaos und für dieses chaos ist
der von merkel und ihren claqueuren
regierte stadt verantwortlich der sich
weigert seine elementarste aufgabe die
innere und äußere sicherheit zu
gewährleisten wahrzunehmen
alles andere sind höchst unerfreuliche
folge reaktionen auf aktion vor reaktion
merkel wollte vorgeblich unschöne bilder
an der grenze verhindern nun hat sie die
unschönen bilder im eigenen land und
meine damen und herren von der presse
das ist eine feststellung mitnichten
eine rechtfertigung die uns in den
medien in solchen fällen auch gerne mal
untergeschoben wird es gibt keine
rechtfertigung dafür das gewaltmonopol
des staates auszuhebeln
das ist unsere klipp und klar und
feststehende position es ist doch
wirklich bemerkenswert dass in den
medien die tatsache dass gegen mord und
totschlag demonstriert wird größere
empörung auszulösen scheint als mord und
totschlag an sich fast alle fast alle
scheinen entsetzt dass in chemnitz
demonstriert wird aber kaum jemand ist
entsetzt dass es einen toten und zwei
schwerverletzte im zuge von importierter
gewalt gab
das könnte nun daran liegen dass mord
und totschlag mittlerweile zur
normalität geworden und nur noch von
regionaler bedeutung sind so verurteilt
die bundesregierung zwar die angeblichen
hetzjagd auch das hat martin sicher
dankenswerterweise schon aufgegriffen
die ist gar nicht gegeben hat aufs
schärfste äußert sich aber nicht über
den eigentlichen auslöser in diesem maße
und ich will das noch ergänzen was
martin sicherte sagte frau merkel hat
zum einen über ihren regierungssprecher
seibert zum anderen höchstpersönlich
diese hetzjagd in chemnitz aufs
schärfste verurteilt von denen der
generalstaatsanwalt sachsens
mittlerweile festgestellt hat es hat sie
gar nicht gegeben
ich stelle dazu fest frau merkel
verbreitet
zählt fake news dafür sollten sie sich
schämen und dass sie zurücktreten sollte
es glaube ich hier common sense das
wollen wir alle und ich glaube auch dass
wir das sehr viel schneller erleben
werden
als wir uns das vielleicht jetzt noch
vorstellen frau merkels zeit läuft ab
die halbwertszeit ist nur noch eine ganz
geringe der der mediale fokus rund um
die geschehnisse in chemnitz ist
identisch
das opfer daniel hill ist nur noch eine
randnotiz wert
oder wird gar da wird wirklich schlimm
ganz geleugnet wie etwa von spiegel
kolumnist georg diez der hat allen
ernstes folgendes getwittert ich zitiere
den tweet wörtlich angela merkel kann zu
chemnitz nicht schweigen oder muss es
erst wieder tote geben
verstehen sie für den tod von daniel
willig war für handys überhaupt kein
platz in seinem denken oder muss es erst
wieder tote geben es hat einen toten
gegeben und hat zwei schwerverletzte
gegeben dass es dem spiegel kolumnisten
keine erwähnung wert er geht schlicht
darüber hinweg weil er sich allein auf
die vorgeblich rechten demonstranten die
die übels im sinn haben und vorgeblich
gewalttätig sind konzentriert wie
zynisch ist das wie abscheulich ist dass
stattdessen eben volle konzentration auf
die demonstranten und rechte gewalt man
hat fast den eindruck dass rechte in
chemnitz gemordet hätten haben sie aber
nicht würden sie auch nicht dass auf
beiden seiten einige verletzte gab ist
bekannt aber haben sie in den medien
auch nur eine silbe von einem wütenden
linken mob vernommen
den gab's dann nämlich auch ich nicht
ein zeit journalist schrieb sogar dass
die lösung für das problem mit dem
rechten mob antifa laute hat er
geschrieben antifa als lösung also ich
hätte da mal er einen rechtsstaat
gedacht und jakob augstein den ich eben
schon erwähnte schrieb zu den
angeblichen hetzjagd wenig stattgefunden
haben mit 0 verletzten polizisten und 0
festnahmen folgendes
und ich zitiere wörtlich das wohl gerne
sehen sie mir nach ich mein das muss man
zitieren wir selbst würden uns
selbstverständlich so nicht ausdrücken
jakob augstein schreibt folgendes
sachsen ist wie das internet nur in echt
der ganze niedrige hass der sich im netz
bahn bricht in sachsen kann man ihn auf
der straße sehen die videos aus chemnitz
zeigen wir die dicken stirner gegen
männer die mit ihren glatzen aussehen
wie pimmel mit ohren allerdings pimmel
mit sonnenbrillen
sie sind das fleischgewordene rülpsen
und tempeln dass die sozialen medien
durchflutet zitat ende
es ist sehr still ja kein wunder sie
sind wahrscheinlich entsetzt ich war es
auch als ich das gelesen habe
derselbe auf stein der nach der kölner
silvesternacht mit 1054 strafanzeigen
darunter 454 sexualdelikten schrieb ein
paar grafischen ausländer und schon
heißt bei uns der firnis der
zivilisation wissen sie man muss solche
leute nur sprechen und schreiben lassen
dann entlarven sie sich selbst diese
berichterstattung meine damen und herren
diese berichterstattung ist pervers
propagandistisch und nur noch
verachtenswert mit journalistischen
ethos mit berichterstattung hat das
nichts aber auch gar nichts mehr zu tun
das nenne ich links faschistische
agitation und sonst gar nichts kopiert
werden menschen die diese grundhaltung
haben dann auch noch vom zwangs
finanzierten öffentlich-rechtlichen
rundfunk heute findet in chemnitz ein
konzert gegen rechts statt live
übertragen von 3sat beworben von
bundespräsident steinmeier höchstselbst
mit am start staatsbank campino der darf
bei so was nie fehlen und martin sichert
erwähnte dass schon die linksradikale
band feine sahne fischfilet gesichert
sie haben ja schon fertig gebracht ich
war noch was sie zu kostprobe aus texten
dieser band gefährlich bitte sehr
ich zitiere deutschland ist scheiße
deutschland ist dreck deutschland
verrecke das wäre wunderbar und anderes
zitat die bullen helme sie sollen
fliegen eure knüppel kriegt er in die
fresse rein
so eine band tritt heute in chemnitz auf
in einer veranstaltung gegen rechts und
wird vom deutschen bundespräsidenten
bitte stellen sie sich das einmal vor
meine damen und herren wir fünf
deutschen bundespräsidenten beworben
dort eingeladen und erhält vom
öffentlichen rundfunk eine bühne
womöglich bekommen die dafür auch noch
eine gage
man muss es in aller deutlichkeit sagen
dieses land ist offenkundig verrückt
geworden nicht wir und nicht via gehören
für verfassungsschutz beobachtet da gibt
es einige andere
höchste zeit also dass es sich endlich
wieder normalisiert und zwar in jeder
hinsicht und hierfür ist ein kompletter
politischer kurswechsel unabdingbar
notwendig mit der kanzler darstellerin
merkel und ihren ihr devot zujubeln
hofschranzen aus dem kartell parteien
einerlei wird das nichts aber der reihe
nach
immer wenn man denkt schlimmer gehts
nicht mehr kommt von irgendwo die merkel
her und setzt noch einen drauf merkel
das ist die ewige raute des staats
versagens diese frau verrät und verkauft
an gewissen besser sagen sie verschenkt
unser vaterland auf eine weise die einem
förmlich den atem stocken lässt und die
seit gründung der bundesrepublik
deutschland ohne jedes beispiel ist was
muss diese frau eigentlich noch alles
anrichten bis der deutsche michel
endlich mehrheitlich begreift dass er in
diesem land keineswegs mehr gut und
gerne leben wird wenn er diese
hohepriesterin des zionismus der macht
angela merkel nicht endlich ihres schon
viel zu lang innegehabt und
missbrauchten amtes endlich enthebt gut
und gerne leben das wurde allen ernstes
noch im letzten bundestagswahlkampf von
merkel und in ihren behauptet obwohl für
noch für jedermann der des sehens noch
halbwegs fähig ist offen zutage liegt
wie dieses land gerade von ihr und ihren
willfährigen helfern immer schneller in
den ruin getrieben wird und zwar
rechtlich finanziell moralisch kulturell
sicherheitspolitisch sie lassen absolut
nichts aus und dann versuchen allen
ernstes ankündigungsminister seehofer
und sein allerbester freund markus söder
eine niere aus ihrer position nur zu
berechtigten panik vor den
bevorstehenden landtagswahlen in bayern
einen auf wir stoppen merkel jetzt zu
machen
der vielzitierte heißluft dort versucht
sich wieder mal in seiner fast schon
peinlichen selbstinszenierung als ganz
harter law and order bursche nur am
rande
wer bei dieser koalitions gesellschaft
nur noch somit leidende seehofer
schreibt wie ich hörte gerade an einem
buch das wir nennen mein kampf ja das am
rande auch damit hat der arme
innenminister nämlich erhebliche
probleme und seien ziemlich besser
parteifreund der der islam gehört zu
bayern oder markus frankiert seine
vorgeblich beinharten attacken gegen
merkel und co aus münchen
pflichtschuldigst ja der mullahs oder
vor paar monaten sagte er noch der islam
gehört nicht zu deutschland wo wir da
recht hat vor einiger zeit klang das war
ihm allerdings noch ganz anders sagte er
nämlich vor der islamistischen die tib
gemeinde in nürnberg der islam ist ein
teil von bayern
da stellt sich die frage ja was ja nun
ja soll ich jetzt hier saufen oder was
dankeschön
solange ich rede gibt es kein bier
gesagt geht es danach aber danke schön
was für einen niedergang was für einen
niedergang meine damen und herren eine
einstmals großen konservativen partei
die einmal von christlich
abendländischer werthaltung geprägt war
heute motors c im namen von cdu wie csu
doch mehr nicht mehr als ein symbol
christlicher grundhaltung an sondern
sieht er die vermutung nahe dass diese
szenen zwischen längs für die halbmond
sicher des islam steht
und das merken allmählich dass das nicht
funktioniert das problem dieser partei
heißt opportunismus bis zur
vollkommenheit franz josef strauß den
ich wirklich sehr geschätzt geradezu
verehrt habe als junger mann dürfte im
grabe rotieren
kommen wir noch mal kurz zurück kommen
wir noch einmal kurz zurück zu horst
seehofer sein letzter vorstoß nichts der
heißluft forschungsthema frauchen muttis
brava ablegt dackel blieb diesmal wir
haben das anfang juli erlebt ein
bisschen standhafter und damit kann
diese ganze inszenierung law and order
ja laufen aber gucken sie sich das mal
genauer an seine knallharte forderung
sieht kurz zusammengefasst vor dass die
einreise von einreisenden mit
einreiseverbot verboten wird
das ist das was da steht das ist das ist
im kern sein masterplan die einreise von
einreisenden mit einreiseverbot soll
verboten werden wo ganz großes politik
kino schauen sie sich auch dieses
bilaterale abkommen mit spanien machen
ihr vater gesagt wir machen da was und
da wilder aktionismus und tatsächlich
der konnte vollzug melden er hat dieses
abkommen mit spanien und was sieht das
nun vor nun das sieht vor dass wenn
menschen aus spanien kommend dort kein
asyl an einen asylantrag gestellt haben
und dann über österreich nach
deutschland einreisen
dass spanien sich dann verpflichtet
diese menschen zurückzunehmen
das finde ich interessant was stellen
sie sich einfach mal vor sie kommen als
mensch aus nordafrika hier rein und
wollen nach deutschland über spanien
erst wenn sie wahrscheinlich hören dass
es da nicht das glücks wesen asylantrag
in spanien zu stellen und lassen das
zweitens glaube ich man muss nicht was
alphabetisiert sein um als bevorzugte
route um von spanien nach deutschland zu
kommen nicht über österreich ein reist
wo man das geringste zu sagen das heißt
das ist ein völlig wirkungslose
schaufenster abkommen und mehr nicht und
wenn wir das nach ein paar wochen
gültigkeit uns einmal anschauen wie
viele
denn davon bis jetzt betroffen waren nun
die zahl lässt sich nennen die ist
nämlich unlängst ermittelt wurden exakt
null
das ist nun nicht übermäßig erstaunlich
das ist das was seehofers knallharte
politik ist und das ist lächerlich
also dass das bisher nicht gängige
praxis ist menschen und medien deshalb
nicht mal ansatzweise rebellieren und
das auch noch als krasse politische
forderung verkauft wird der sich die
kanzler darstellerin nicht vorbehaltlos
anschließen kann lässt wiederum nur ein
fazit zu deutschland ist rein rechtlich
zu einer art bananenrepublik verkommen
die international nur noch belächelt
wird ich krieg das mit weil ich sehr
viele internationale kontakte habe und
ich kann ihnen sagen als deutscher
das schmerzt mich das tut mir weh das
ausland lacht über uns sie lachen sich
schlapp über und sie sind entsetzt die
erkenntnis dieses cdu/csu trauerspiel
der vergangenen monate ist komplett
ernüchternd bereits die homöopathische
durchsetzung geltenden rechts wirkt
angesichts der zur bleibenden normalität
geworden ist zur normalität geworden
rechtsbruchs merkels und ihrer devoten
hofschranzen fast schon forsch und das
einfordern von rückkehr zu recht gesetz
und ordnung gilt hierzulande fast schon
als braun rechts
das mit verlaub wenn ich krank dass es
fast schon irre und die quittung dafür
die gibt's vom wähler von umfrage zu
umfrage schwinden die prozentpünktchen
für die unionsparteien von der spd
brauchen wir gar nicht mehr zu reden die
harten arbeiten hat eine einstelligkeit
und ich glaube die schaffen das
[Applaus]
übrigens sehr interessant wenn wenn
davon große die rede ist ja also wenn
das eine große koalition ist die haben
zusammen das war sogar überlegen cdu csu
spd keine 50 prozent mehr
das geht immer weiter runter interessant
zu sehen werden die sich dann auch groko
nennen es muss also absehbar ein neuer
koalitionspartner her und was läge der
vermerkten union näher als ich da mal
umzuschauen und dann werden sie fündig
nicht hier in bayern sondern bundesweit
respektive bei bevorstehenden
landtagswahlen dem osten die nächstes
jahr kommen bei der sed nachfolgepartei
die linke
man denke nur an die neuerlichen
vorstöße von daniel günther der ja so
etwas wie merkel in männlich ist nun ja
günther sinniert über koalition mit der
linken ein abgrund der
prinzipienlosigkeit aber nichts neues
wer sich ernsthaft über künftige
koalition zwischen union und linken
wundert meine damen und herren hat dass
es dem merkel noch nicht verstanden dass
heißt machterhalt um wirklich jeden
preis aber das system wird implodieren
wie dich die cdu an die linkspartei
gerückt ist zeigt neulich ein pos der
konrad-adenauer-stiftung zum 47
jahrestag des mauerbaus erinnerte die
stiftung nicht etwa an die von den ddr
grenztruppen erschossenen menschen
sondern zeigte fotos von neuen mauern
und sperranlagen unter anderem den usa
mexiko und den zaun der spanischen mauer
in ca ob ein land die eigenen bürger mit
mauern und minen gürtel einsperrt und
beim fluchtversuch nieder schießt oder
ob es illegale einwanderer draußen
halten will oder sich vor
selbstmordattentätern schützt aus sicht
der cdu csu neuen typs gibt es
diesbezüglich offenbar keinen
nennenswerten unterschied mehr
beim ddr geschichtsrevisionismus liegen
merkels kader also schon einmal auf
einer ebene mit den erben der sed
eigentlich könnte sich die cdu auch um
landon in dkp deutsche kanzlerin partei
schließlich geht es dieser schließlich
geht es dieser partei einzig und allein
um die kanzlerschaft
das war einer solchen umbenennung von
assoziationen zur deutschen
kommunistischen partei geweckt werden
würden passt eigentlich gar nicht
schlecht und besonders amüsant während
die union über koalition mit kommunisten
sinniert ganz offen und öffentlich warnt
das feuilleton der mainstream medien vor
einem rechtsruck der cdu csu das genau
mal in humor also wirklich schräg
mittlerweile hat die union die
unrühmliche rolle der fdp angenommen
letztes jahr weiß ich nur habe ich hier
will jeder muss gesagt die fdp ist die
wandernde matratze der deutschen
parteienlandschaft meine damen und
herren das kann man heute über cdu csu
sagen und die diese linke die irrlichter
momentan so um dass weiten teilen der
partei einfach zu bunt wird die neue
linke sammlungsbewegung von sahra
wagenknecht nennt sich auf stehen ob der
name aufstehen für sahra wagenknecht
linke sammlungsbewegung wirklich so
geeinigt ist das arbeitsscheue anti
falten million erreicht man damit
jedenfalls eher nicht sie bleiben lieber
etwas länger liegen oder aber und das
scheint mir hier in bayern die
wahrscheinlichere variante zu sein
die union bietet sich noch weiter den
grünen an
ich komme aus baden württemberg da ist
das längst gelebte realität um mit ihnen
womöglich hier in bayern eine koalition
bilden zu können
die werden ja momentan von der fahrt bis
zur taz hochgeschrieben allen voran
wegen ihres neuen parteivorsitzenden
habeck und ganz plötzlich entdecken die
grünen den heimatbegriff für sich der
titel von fedex jüngst zu ende gegangen
der sommertour lautet in anlehnung an
unsere nationalhymne des glückes
unterpfand er inszeniert sich jetzt als
echter grüner patriot meine damen und
herren ich habe da meine zweifel
und wie gesagt man muss die leute reden
lassen dann wird vieles deutlich
vorgesetzte von habeck werden
massenmedial bisher nicht so stark
rezipiert ich will das aber ganz bewusst
hier mal in die diskussion bringen
habeck wörtlich vaterlandsliebe fand ich
stets zum kotzen mit deutschland wusste
ich nichts anzufangen und ich weiß es
bis heute nicht
zitat ende robert habeck große heimat
liebe muss man sagen das spricht für
sich ein wahrer patriot dieser habeck
nein meine damen und herren haben so
eine grünen sind keine alternative zum
altparteien einerlei sondern sie sind ja
sogar aller übelsten katalysatoren des
zerfalls deutschlands sie sind keine
patrioten sondern sie sind deutschland
taster national masten und heuchler
süchtig nach immer mehr einwanderung
nach immer mehr multikulti dafür stehen
die grünen
und da passt das nur zu gut dass die
grünen über den asylstatus
klimaflüchtlinge sanieren inzwischen die
finden also einen weiteren asylgrund
jetzt die sogenannte klimakrise soll
künftig als fluchtgrund anerkannt werden
ricarda lang bundessprecherin der grünen
jugend aus dem kompetenzzentrum dieser
republik sagte sagte wortwörtlich die eu
sollte den bewohnern von inselstaaten
die durch den klimawandel bedroht sind
die europäische staatsbürgerschaft
anbieten und ihnen eine würdevolle
migration ermöglichen
wenn also das wetter immer schlechter
wird soll betroffenen insulanern eine eu
staatsbürgerschaft geschenkt werden
schließlich sind wir wahrscheinlich als
böse alte weiße europäische männer
maßgeblich schuld am klimawandel
was für ein pathologischer altruismus
meine damen und herren
und übrigens ganz am rande auch ein
bisschen rassistisch von der guten frau
weil das ist nicht ganz fair gegenüber
menschen die vielleicht bei steigendem
meeresspiegel auch dann kein land mehr
haben die aber nicht insulaner sind also
in bangladesch zb wird man das wenig
begeistert aufnehmen denn bangladesch
ist keine insel
die will die frau nicht aufnehmen aber
die anderen dann schon das alles ist
völlig gutes zeug und dieser ganze
pathologische altruismus folgt der
devise der grusel grünen grande katrin
göring eckardt
ein name ein geständnis könnte man sagen
sie
sie versichert uns willkommenskultur ist
der beste schutz vor terroristen
wenn die hütte brennt einfach noch mehr
benzin rein gießen das ist grüne logik
und dann baute der grüne
parteivorsitzende habe dazu passend uns
kann man auch die innere sicherheit an
vertrauen
das ist vermutlich eine genau so
grandiose idee wie wenn man den
greenfreeze so nenne ich die immer das
steht für grün fundamente wunder
mentalist ish realitätsfremde intensiv
schweizer die verantwortung über die
energiepolitik anvertrauen würde müsste
er eigentlich deren domäne sein
es ist ja nicht bloß so dass die grünen
einzig auf den themengebieten lang wären
auf denen man ihnen sowieso keine
kompetenz zugetraut hätte wie innere
sicherheit nein es ist noch viel
schlimmer die haben auch keine ahnung
von den feldern wo sie ahnung haben
müssen wie zum beispiel der
energiepolitik auch da glänzen sie mit
einer erstaunlichen ahnungslosigkeit
es gab ja mal zeiten da machten sich die
menschen noch jede erdenkliche mühe die
geheimnisvollen gesetze der natur mit
allerlei kniffen in ihren religiös oder
ideologische dominierten welt
erklärungsmodell unterzubringen
man denke hier etwa griechische
mythologie am zeus der für donner und
blitz verantwortlich gewesen sein soll
solche mythen wurden aber eines tages
dann von der wirklichkeit eingeholt
wurden
na ja nicht alle es gibt ja auch moderne
mythen und für den großteil dieser
modernen mythen ist die grüne partei
verantwortlich
allen voran die so auch ihre würdigung
finden hier die neue co-vorsitzende
annalena baerbock
die angesprochen auf die
stromversorgungs sicherheit ernsthaft
folgendes entgegnete auch die soll
wörtlich zitiert werden weil es so schön
ist dieser wir exportieren ein zehntel
unseres stroms ins ausland in andere
länder
die osteuropäischen staaten haben schon
gesagt so geht das nicht weiter ihr
verstopft unsere netze
deswegen haben wir gesagt diese zehn
export die können wir an kohle vom netz
nehmen und natürlich gibt es
schwankungen das vollkommen klar tagen
wie diesen wo es grau ist da haben wir
natürlich viel weniger erneuerbare
energien
deswegen haben wir speichern deswegen
fungiert das netz als speicher ich habe
schwierigkeiten dabei ernst zu bleiben
und das ist alles ausgerechnet zitat
ende
frau berg wir haben keine stromexporte
man ist ja auch kein müll exporte wenn
man dafür bezahlt dass einmal pro woche
die müllabfuhr kommt und wie komplett
wie komplett kenntnis los muss man
eigentlich sein um anzunehmen dass das
netz als speicher fungiere und dann sein
hat alles auch noch ausgerechnet frau
berbalk bitte präsentieren sie doch mal
diese rechnung ich bin schon gespannt
natürlich gibt es diese rechnung von der
die frau da faselt nicht genauso wenig
wie das netz als speicher fungiert oder
fungieren kann
wir haben es hier schlichtweg wird eine
dunkel flaute zu tun und zwar eine
dunkel flaute im kopf von annalena
baerbock
ich hätte eine andere lösung für die
energiepolitik die findet vielleicht hin
bayern angegangen wir lassen einfach im
bundestag unseren gottfried curio im
bundestag noch ein bisschen reden
die dabei entstehende wärme die im
knallroten kopf von anton hofreiter
entsteht könnte man vielleicht irgendwie
in energie umwandeln dann hätte endlich
mal ein grüner etwas wirklich gutes
getan
wir konstatieren den grünen die
verantwortung auf dem gebiet der
migrationspolitik anzuvertrauen keine
gute idee den grünen die verantwortung
auf dem gebiet der inneren sicherheit
anzuvertrauen erst recht keine gute idee
den grünen die verantwortung auf dem
gebiet der energiepolitik anvertrauen
dunkel flaute und wie schaut es mit den
sozialen sicherungssystemen aus können
die wenigstens das geht so schließlich
brauchen wir laut göring eckardt nicht
nur fachkräfte unter den migranten
sondern auch solche auch das ist ein
wörtliches zitat die sich in unseren
sozialsystemen wohl und zu hause fühlen
ein iq von 150 ist ja eine super sache
blöd nur wenn sich die ganze partei
teilen muss meine damen und herren
obwohl wohl in unseren sozialsystemen
fühlte sich auch samia der leibwächter
von osama bin laden den wir ja nun
fdp-mann kubicki um nahezu jeden preis
in unserem land halten
schließlich gehe ist ja um die
einhaltung rechtsstaatlicher prinzipien
so plötzlich entdeckt die fdp ihre
vorliebe für rechtsstaatliche prinzipien
das ist interessant bei der illegalen
masseneinwanderung stimmte christian
lindner höchstselbst 2016 noch brav ein
in den chor der multikulti besoffenen
dann hieß es bei ihm noch ganz laut
rechte jazz wolken und von
rechtsstaatlichkeit war keine rede
kurz vor der bundestagswahl dann als die
fatalen folgen der politik der offenen
grenzen schonungslos zutage traten und
ein umdenken in der bevölkerung
stattfand forderte derselbe länder
plötzlich eine rigorose abschiebepolitik
oder bei der sogenannten euro- rettung
entgegen freiheitlicher prinzipien
machte die magenta haben einen nominalen
liberaler lars dem ganzen euro rettungs
irrsinn widerrechtlich mit entgegen dem
maastricht-vertrag aber bei sanaa
da gelten bei der fdp auf einmal nun
ganz andere nämlich strikt
rechtsstaatliche maßstäbe ja ich glaube
als prinzipientreu und standfestigkeit
verteilt wurden hat die fdp gerade
verstecken gespielt
stattdessen stattdessen mit treiben
lieber gesinnungs akrobatik so landet
man dann eben schnell bei dafür steht
der fdp fast drei prozent da sind die
noch nicht ganz wieder aber die arbeiten
schon wieder daran
und in diese richtung bewegt sich auch
eine partei die bisher unerwähnt blieb
irgendwie nimmt man die gar nicht mehr
so richtig war
sie werden sich erinnern spd heißt diese
partei von der hört und sieht man nicht
mehr viel und das ist auch besser so
und für seine partei die spezial
demokraten wie ich die immer ne ne ist
es vorbei mit dem dasein also als
volkspartei ich weiß ja auch nicht wer
sind eigentlich diese 17 prozent der
wähler die dieser chaostruppe immer noch
ihre stimme bereit sind zu geben
das müssen irgendwie ganz ausgeprägt
christen seien die spd in er hat sich in
einem atemberaubenden tempo einer
situation in der sie mehr mitglieder als
wähler hat liebe freunde und viele der
motivierten parteioberen arbeiten mit
feuereifer daran dass schon bald zu
erreichen
ich habe heute nacht das habe ich habe
es heute morgen erfahren hat mich
ruhiger schlafen lassen die die nacht im
gleichen hotel verbracht wie andrea
nahles
gut dass ich das vorher nicht wusste ich
hab euch und gut geschlafen
von andrea nahles lässt sich sagen dass
wenn sie redet das einzig gute daran ist
dass sie dann wenigsten nicht sinkt eine
parteivorsitzende deren filigrane ja
geradezu fein ziselierte rhetorik sich
zb in der feinsinnigen ankündigung
vollendete der cdu künftig in die fresse
geben zu wollen
mithin nebenbei jener partei mit der es
ihr wenige monate später gar nicht
schnell genug gehen konnte erneut ins
warme koalitions bettchen zu hüpfen
neuerdings hat andrea nahles ja ein
spurwechsel gefordert bei ihrem
spurwechsel geht es darum abgelehnten
asylbewerbern eine bleibeperspektive zu
geben wenn sie in die sich integrieren
ohne arbeit haben
liebe frau nahles wenn man als
politische geisterfahrerin einen
spurwechsel hinlegt dann bleibt man
immer noch eine geisterfahrerin nur
solch kleiner tipp am rande
wobei mir der spd durchaus dankbar sind
das muss man auch erwähnen
die hat ja noch andere spitzenpersonal
ralf im volksmund auch pöbel ralle
genannt stegner der in der ihm eigenen
gewalt affinität auf twitter dazu
aufgerufen hat nicht nur die opposition
sondern auch das personal der afg zu
attackieren
ein mann der aufpassen muss dass er nach
der nächsten meinungsumfrage für seine
partei nicht über seine eigenen
mundwinkel stolpert man es nicht
verwinden kann dass die menschen in
unserem land gerade die vielzitierten
kleinen leute die früher mal ein spd
gewählt haben längst verstanden haben
wenn sie seit jahren verraten und
verkauft hat mit der ganzen absurden
europa und euro rettungspolitik wie mit
der öffnung der grenzen für jedermann
[Applaus]
und in einer sozialpolitik deluxe
menschen aus aller herren länder bei
gleichzeitiger vernachlässigung der
wirklich bedürftigen die in diesem land
allein in den malus haben deutsche zu
sein
meine damen und herren ich thematisiere
das hier nicht weil ich es langsam zum
ende kommen
ich deute das nur mal kurz an wir geben
für sozialpolitik in diesem land weitaus
mehr geld aus als für alle anderen
bereich in öffentlichen haushalten
wir haben wenn sie alle sozialhaushalte
zusammenfassen mittlerweile
sozialausgaben von knapp einer billion
euro also fast 1000 milliarden und
gleichzeitig sicher nicht nur ich alte
menschen an mülltonnen tatsächlich nach
leergut suchen und das eine beobachtung
die habe ich wirklich und ernsthaft
selber mehr als einmal gemacht und da
muss ich sagen da leichter irgend etwas
fundamental schief wenn wir einerseits
unglaubliche mengen an geld für
sozialpolitik ausgeben und andererseits
alter menschen im müllcontainer nach
leergut suchen müssen
da ist ein staatsversagen auf ganzer
ebene dass einem die worte ob die spd
die spd hat immer noch nicht kapiert
dass ihr geradezu impertinenten und
penetrantes fordern von gerechtigkeit
bei gleichzeitiger entkriminalisierung
von ladendieben schwarzfahrer
drogenkonsumenten asylbetrügern beim
traditionellen gesetzestreuen malocher
gibt es relativ viele der einst das
rückgrat der partei bildete nicht
wirklich gut ankommen aber vorher genau
diese leute und das versteht die spd
nehme ich hoffe daran halten die fest
schön für uns genau für diese menschen
geht es jetzt die alternative für
deutschland und ich bitte die spd
höflich dass ralf stegner ihren
zentralen funktionen noch lange erhalten
bleibt wir haben keinen besseren
wahlkämpfer als ihm
liebe freunde ist es unübersehbar dass
die politischen zustände in diesem land
inzwischen einer tragikomischen
realsatire gleichen darüber kann man
sich lustig machen und manchmal tut's
auch gut über die herrschenden zustände
und auch über sich selbst lachen zu
können
ich tue das auch gern niemand sollte
sich selbst zu ernst nehmen aber das was
ich in diesem land mittlerweile zu trägt
ist nicht zum lachen ist eigentlich viel
zu gefährlich als dass es mit ein paar
derben sprüchen einfach abgetan werden
könnte unser land unsere heimat die
zukunft unserer kinder ist in größter
gefahr wenn wir diese ganzen satten
selbstgefälligen sich in moralischer
selbst besessenheit sohlen kartell
parteienvertreter unser land weiter
ruinieren lassen
geben wir also den echten satire kann
wieder arbeit indem wir das volk in
merkels unsäglicher diktion die länger
hier schon lebenden die länger hier
schon regierenden nachhaltig aus ihren
ämtern vertreiben
das ist die aufgabe und das ist bitter
notwendig in bayern können sie das am 14
tun sie können einen substanziellen
beitrag dazu leisten
ich bitte sie inständig für die zukunft
dieses wundervollen freistaates bayern
geben sie ihre stimme am 14 10 und der
alternative für deutschland nutzen sie
die gelegenheit vielen herzlichen dank
[Applaus]